1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 these are three
terms in what kind of progression
what kind have a look this is a this is
a geometric progression here's how I
know when I'm um when I was because of
the humidity about turning on but anyway
when I look at one term to the next the
rule that gets me from one to the next
and to the next and so on looks like
it's multiplication by a common ratio in
this case that ratio is ah notice it now
because I've given you three of these
this is not just a geometry of
progression I could say that this equals
the partial sum of a geometric
progression it's the first three terms
yeah and we know how to do partial sums
we developed our formula for partial
sums for a PS we did it for GPS
everything was fine okay but what we
haven't tackled is what happens if I say
I don't just want you to add up three I
don't even want you to add up ten or
10,000 what if I said I wanted you to
add up all of them now
when I say all this is an infinite
series right Ryan at the beginning of
this topic I said some sequences end you
know it's like one to ten there you go
counting numbers on my hands but some
sequences do not the set of all the
sequence of all odd numbers 1 3 5 7 11 9
11 there's no end right this geometric
sequence progression series also does
not end so how can we say that it's
equal to something to some number okay
the way that we can approach this is to
think about what happens to this object
as we approach infinity as we approach
infinity if only I had an area of math
that help me work out when I approach
something with like never quite get
there or wait
I do when you want to get closer and
closer and closer to something something
that you're not actually ever supposed
to be able to get to like say this guy
right
when you think about the object 1 over X
when you think about the hyperbola it
never gets to X equals 0
does it but you can still think about
the limit yes so the limit is what I'm
going to use it's the tool I'm going to
use to work out this right I'm going to
say that the sum of this entire series
is equal to the limit as n gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger
in fact as it approaches infinity of
this series ok so I want the entire
series so I'll Chuck limits around all
of here dot dot now because I'm saying
oh to an N I'm just gonna make that the
last term now by the way what is the
last term what is the nth term if there
are n terms in the entire series have a
look think carefully hmm now it's
tempting to say you get to 0 right but
in fact if you look carefully no matter
how long you go you will never get to 0
just like this guy right you could go on
for millions and billions of years and
you'd still never get to 0 ok in this
case I believe correct me if I'm wrong
you're gonna have one on 2 to the end
yeah because look the first term is 1
onto the second term is 1 on 2 squared
the third term is 1 on 2 cubed so the
nth term we 1 on 2 to the N so I'm
trying to think about this object with
this limit applied now faithfully I
actually know what the sum of this whole
thing is because this the way I've
written it in here this guy is a partial
sum right do you see that object there
is finite the whole object is not but
the thing in the brackets is ok so this
is a partial sum that means I can use my
formula for a partial song yeah let's
have a look I've got the limit
flying out here just like when we did it
in first principles it is a bit tiresome
to write limit limit limit sounds
like a frog but you have to you have to
because without putting a limit on it's
a finite object but when you do put the
limit on it's an infinite object and
these are quite different like there's
an infinite amount of difference between
finite and infinite okay so I've put the
limit there and now I think what is
actually this song well you've got a
formula in fact I'm know I didn't bring
my other colors with me
you might remember there's two forms
that we learnt for this GP okay they
both start with a and they're both
fractions but they slightly differ
do you remember what give me one of them
either one doesn't matter ah to the N
minus one which means on the bottom
there's gonna be a minus one so that's a
version one if you like or you could
start with an A you still infraction
what's the difference yeah just things I
flipped around yes so I would have 1
minus out of the N and 1 minus R I can't
have a think look at what kind of series
we have particularly have a look at the
coloured ratio that gets you from time
to time which do you think might be
easier to work with I think the second
one because if you stick a half in here
you get a negative that means you get a
negative double negatives gross I prefer
to go over here okay in fact basically
when R is between negative 1 and 1 we
basically use this version here okay no
between 0 1 sorry yeah sorry I'm going
to use that form with all of the
appropriate pieces what 8 what's the
first term aha
there it is so brackets let's have a
look 1/2 I've got 1
- now coincidentally in this case the
ratio is also 1/2 so be careful it's the
whole ratio raised to the power of n
like so and then all my denominator I
have yep yeah 1 - are there yeah hey
you'll talk to me later
there's the partial sum end bracket okay
now I'm gonna have to deal with this
limit in a second but before I do that
there's plenty I could tidy up here yeah
for example what's the denominator end
up being a half and I've got a half
there so it's like bam bam
great so now all I get left really well
let's write this properly without the
cancelled bits limit as n approaches
infinity of this thing that's all that
gets left behind so it's going to be one
take away this okay think think think
think think this is what I mean by
abstract right this object doesn't exist
in reality at least not the kind of
reality we're used to dealing with how
do I deal with this we've dealt with
limits before we haven't sometimes had
to do manipulation because like oh you
can't put in you can't just substitute
the number in like h equals zero in
first principles can i put this can i
can i put it into here infinity is not a
number but it's an idea it's a really
huge quantity right and what i'm
applying it to is this number okay so in
other words what that means is this
number is going to get enormous a
hundred a thousand a million and so on
when you multiply 1/2 by itself that
many times what happens to it it gets
tiny right it approaches zero but but
because I'm talking about limits I can
say I can actually treat it as zero so I
can say this is one take away zero right
I've evaluated the limit now no more
ends so that's why I can stop saying
limit so this apparently equals what now
this is a way of saying hey you've got
this infinite object right but let's
place a sorry there's infinite object
let's place a finite value on it if it
can follow these rules because we didn't
pull any rabbits out of a hat that
really does approach zero right
not all sequences will do this for
example if I didn't give you 1/2 plus
1/4 if I gave you the reciprocals 2
4+8 etc that's not converging on
anything that's not going toward
anything is just getting bigger and
bigger forever but this guy because it
gets smaller and smaller forever
it does approach something so what we do
is because we've worked out a sum but
it's not just any sum we've used limits
to get there the title of this object is
called the limiting sum okay so another
way of thinking about this is what do
the partial sums approach what do the
partial sums approach to help you see
that a little clearer
watch what happens if I actually write a
few more terms out okay so the next time
of course we won over 16 then 1 over 32
and I'll just do one more now if you
think about what the partial sums are
these numbers are I keep forgetting I
left my other color on my desk that's
fine no no spares that have been left
around if I think about the partial sum
of the first human me1 term what's the
partial sum of the first one term it's
just the first term
I'm just going to write it above and I'm
gonna put in a circle that's the first
partial sum
what's the second partial sign it's 1/2
plus 1/4 which is 3/4 do you see that if
I take the third partial Sun 3/4 that's
umm how many eighths is that that's 6
eighths so when you add another one you
get 7/8 now can you follow the pattern
without having to actually do this with
the dories you're going to get fifteen
sixteenths right fifteen sixteenths and
then you're gonna get thirty one thirty
seconds and sixty three sixty fourths
and so on so do you see how the limiting
song is it literally means what do these
partial sums approach they curly
approach one okay